Traduttore: Asia Carafa
Revisore: Sofia Ramundo
Il mondo del lavoro
sta cambiando profondamente
sotto la spinta di forze che
vanno ben oltre i confini nazionali.
Forze come il progresso tecnologico,
la globalizzazione,
che, essendo molto più grandi di noi
ci fanno sentire come in balia delle onde,
come incapaci di governare i processi
di trasformazione di cui siamo parte.
Invece, il messaggio
che cercherò di lasciarvi oggi
è che la trasformazione
del mondo del lavoro
si può e si deve governare,
attraverso politiche economiche
coraggiose che, più di ogni altra cosa,
puntino a ridurre le disuguaglianze
che stanno aumentando
nel mercato del lavoro,
e che rischiano
di destabilizzare la nostra società.
Cominciamo dalla premessa
che il mondo, effettivamente,
è composto di processi produttivi
che sono diventati
sempre più tecnologicamente avanzati
e sempre più integrati a livello globale.
Per darvi un esempio, l'iPhone
che, sicuramente, alcuni di voi
ora avranno in tasca in questa sala
si compone di parti che arrivano
da oltre 43 paesi diversi.
L'aereo che mi ha portato qui oggi
viene assemblato con componenti
che vengono prodotti
da mille aziende diverse
in più di 30 paesi.
Quindi, come capite benissimo,
la globalizzazione
e il processo tecnologico
stanno trasformando
il modo in cui produciamo
e in cui lavoriamo;
e questo crea delle preoccupazioni,
perché le aziende possono
vedere fette di mercato
volatilizzarsi con l'arrivo di un'app,
perché i lavoratori pensano
di trovarsi in difficoltà,
in ritardo rispetto alla tecnologia
e rispetto ai rischi
che il mondo del lavoro pone.
Sono due le preoccupazioni
che aleggiano principalmente
nella mente dei lavoratori: la prima,
stanno arrivando i robot
e ci ruberanno il lavoro;
la seconda, i nostri lavori
stanno semplicemente
andando verso posti del mondo
dove la manodopera costa meno.
Comunque la si voglia
analizzare la questione,
quindi, qualunque delle due forze
pensiamo sia la più importante,
secondo me, c'è una domanda
fondamentale che occorre porre
perché c'è nella mente delle persone.
A causa di questi trend,
è effettivamente vero
che dobbiamo preoccuparci
di un aumento della disoccupazione,
di una riduzione del lavoro nel futuro,
perché magari le macchine faranno tutto?
La risposta, secondo noi, è no.
È no, perché in realtà è vero:
le macchine stanno avanzando.
Qui vi mostro la produzione
di robot per uso industriale,
che sta aumentando tantissimo,
ma, allo stesso tempo,
durante questo periodo
di esplosione tecnologica,
è avanzato anche il tasso di impiego.
Incredibilmente, nonostante i robot
distruggessero il lavoro
nell'insieme, l'impiego è aumentato.
Da vent'anni fa,
a prima della crisi, a oggi;
nella maggior parte dei paesi, non tutti.
Ma il trend, sicuramente,
non è negativo: com'è possibile?
Beh, innanzitutto, sfatiamo un mito:
è possibile perché la tecnologia
non distrugge soltanto lavoro.
l'automazione, anzi, ne crea
più di quanto ne distrugga.
Come lo fa?
Essenzialmente, rendendoci più produttivi,
permettendoci di aver bisogno
di meno tempo
per produrre le stesse risorse,
e quindi liberando tempo e ricchezza
che possiamo dedicare a nuove attività,
generando nuovo lavoro.
Cosa fa, invece, la globalizzazione?
Crea degli squilibri, delle difficoltà.
E ci arriveremo.
Ma allo stesso tempo crea lavoro.
In Italia, il 35% dei lavori
nel settore privato
sono lavori che dipendono direttamente
dalla domanda estera.
È una cifra enorme, che vi fa riflettere,
in un periodo in cui sentiamo
parlare di guerre commerciali,
di dazi, barriere e così via.
Quindi, con questa premessa
ci viene da chiederci:
qual è il problema?
Perché tanta preoccupazione
se la globalizzazione e la tecnologia
aumentano più di ridurre il lavoro?
Beh, il problema
è che non tutti nell'economia
beneficiano allo stesso modo
dal cambiamento tecnologico
e dai benefici della globalizzazione.
È vero, in totale i lavori aumentano,
però alcuni sicuramente vengono distrutti
e secondo l'OCSE è il 14% dei lavori,
la cifra che indica quanti lavori siano
a rischio di essere automatizzati
nella prossima decade o due.
Il punto è che questi lavori non sono
equamente distribuiti nella popolazione.
Sono le fasce più deboli, i lavoratori
con competenze inferiori
quelli che tipicamente si trovano
più svantaggiati.
E quindi, il punto fondamentale
della questione
è preoccuparsi dell'aumento
delle disparità e delle disuguaglianze
che creano esattamente il tipo di tensioni
che vediamo ogni giorno
nella nostra società.
Tensioni tra chi guadagna e chi perde.
Tensioni tra chi beneficia
e tra chi beneficia meno
dei cambiamenti in corso.
Occorre dire un'altra cosa.
Questa non è una storia nuova.
La tecnologia ha sempre trasformato
il mondo del lavoro.
Tanti lavori sono spariti in passato.
Però oggi siamo nella posizione
di poter aiutare quelli
che da queste trasformazioni
si trovano più svantaggiati,
perchè abbiamo i mezzi
e abbiamo imparato di più
su come farlo.
Quindi la domanda fondamentale
che occorre porre
e dare una risposta
assolutamente affermativa è:
occorre intervenire sul mercato del lavoro
per ridurre queste disuguaglianze?
E la risposta è: assolutamente sì.
Direi, ne va della stabilità
della nostra società.
Come?
Ci sono una serie di aree di politica
economica che potremmo toccare,
troppe, per il tempo a disposizione.
Concentriamoci su quelle
che ci preoccupano di più.
Il primo argomento
è quello della formazione.
Qui parliamo di formazione
per adulti, non di scuola.
Voglio darvi qualche cifra su cosa fa
e come funziona il sistema di formazione
per adulti, per quelli che sono già
nel mercato del lavoro e magari
per via di un cambiamento tecnologico
hanno bisogno di riqualificarsi
e in un mondo in cui la tecnologia
è sempre più veloce, o può esserlo,
diventa sempre più importante
avere strumenti del genere.
Ebbene, i sistemi di formazione
che abbiamo oggi
fanno esattamente il contrario
di quello che dovrebbero fare.
Danno più formazione ai lavoratori
che hanno già più competenze,
e danno meno formazione ai lavoratori
che si trovano di fronte
un rischio di automazione maggiore.
I lavoratori con competenze inferiori
che avrebbero più bisogno di formazione
e quelli che si trovano
più facilmente a fronteggiare
il rischio dell'automazione,
di perdere il lavoro perché
arriva una macchina e li rimpiazza,
ricevono meno formazione, non di più
di quelli che hanno rischi inferiori.
La seconda area che ci preoccupa
in un mondo in cui il lavoro
diventa sempre più precario,
e l'abbiamo visto,
perché abbiamo dati che ci dimostrano che
la stabilità dei lavori sta diminuendo,
è il sistema della previdenza sociale
che non è preparato ad aiutare le persone
nelle transizioni del mercato del lavoro.
Nei paesi OCSE due lavoratori su tre
non ricevono sussidi di disoccupazione
quando ne hanno bisogno.
Infine, in un mondo
in cui aziende sempre più grandi
hanno potere di mercato sempre maggiore,
il potere negoziale
dei lavoratori diminuisce.
E questo tra le altre cose è legato
a una diminuzione dei tassi
di sindacalizzazione più o meno ovunque.
Potremmo toccare tante altre
aree di interesse
ma ovviamente non ce n'è il tempo.
Però il messaggiò con cui vorrei
concludere è che, come dicevo all'inizio,
il futuro è nelle nostre mani, nel senso
che non siamo su una nave
in balia delle onde, che non si può
guidare in alcun modo.
E attraverso politiche coraggiose
possiamo effettivamente puntare
a un mondo che sia più equo e più giusto.
Come lo facciamo? Lo facciamo
con politiche di lungo periodo
che siano mirate a ridurre
le disuguaglianze nel lungo periodo
e non soltanto a vincere
le prossime elezioni.
Lo facciamo avendo il coraggio
di ammettere che le riforme
che abbiamo discusso oggi sono riforme
che hanno bisogno di risorse,
non si fanno gratis.
E queste risorse vanno trovate
con una fiscalità più equa ed efficace
e riducendo gli sprechi.
Occorre anche rendersi conto
che per problemi globali
come quelli che abbiamo discusso oggi,
servono soluzioni globali.
E pensare di fare da soli,
da staterelli singoli
in un mondo in cui le forze
in gioco sono così forti
è futile, anacronistico, forse
addirittura pericoloso.
E infine concluderei dicendo
che diminuire le disuguaglianze
attraverso le politiche che abbiamo
discusso brevemente oggi e attraverso
anche altri strumenti
non vuol dire soltanto
aiutare chi sta peggio.
Vuol dire aiutarci tutti.
Perché una società più divisa,
una società più conflittuale,
una società che per via di queste
divisioni tende anche potenzialmente
verso gli estremismi,
è una società economicamente più debole,
e anche probabilmente una società
più infelice per tutti.
Grazie.
[Applausi]